ben swan journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir ban soit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donald
trump qui compte donc demander
réparation à la chine alors déjà est ce
que c'est possible et ce que l'on peut
prendre au sérieux le tonitruant
président américain je pense il va
certainement demander des réparations
mais je ne pense pas qu'il va en obtenir
il s'agit d'un mot d'une stratégie très
politique
il est très important pour le président
thein trump qu'il avait tout l'attention
vers la chine autant que possible là car
nous sommes maintenant dans l'année de
l'élection présidentielle et il fait
tout son possible pour ne pas endosser
la responsabilité de ce qui arrive à
l'économie suite à sa crise couronna
virus
le nombre de décès aux états unis est
encore assez bas environ 50 mille morts
liés au corona virus les nombres ne sont
pas énormes bien plus bas que ce qui
avait été prévu mais les dégâts sur
l'économie sont très importants et donc
le pressent fait tout ce qu'il peut pour
détourner les responsabilités alors ben
swan lors d'un procès classique
j'imagine c'est la même chose aux etats
unis quand on demande un préjudice en
général on apporte une forme de preuve
du préjudice qu'on a subies et surtout
voilà deux de la culpabilité de celui
qui nous a fait subir ce préjudice sur
quoi se basent donald trump sérieusement
les présidences fonde sur une série
d'idées
beaucoup d'experts de la maison blanche
ainsi que le truc de natanz communique
beaucoup derniers temps et disent que la
chine est responsable du coronavirus car
ils pensent comme le pense est conseillé
que le virus a été créé dans un
laboratoire à bourg ain
puis ils ont affirmé que le gouvernement
chinois n'a pas dit au public que
c'était le cas après que le virus se
soit échappé ils ont laissé le virus se
répand dans le monde entier dont les
états unis et contaminé à des
populations alors que la chine
n'acceptez pas à la sévérité la gravité
du virus et prétend également que la
chine a minimisé d'épidémie en chine
donc ils atteignent ce tableau de la
chine qui crée un problème et qui
ensuite essaye de le cacher plutôt que
d'être honnête
il dit que si la chine avait été honnête
alors les états unis auraient répondu a
réagi très différemment et la nouvelle
affirmation c'est que la chine retient
sur son territoire des équipements de
protection personnelle afin que le virus
continue à se propager aux états unis
sans les masques des gants et tous ces
équipements de protection
et effectivement c'est vrai la chine a
beaucoup de ses équipements mais disent
qu'il s'agit de qualité de contrôler la
qualité et cela cause beaucoup de
frustration auprès des entreprises
américaines disent qu'ils ne reçoivent
rien comment réagissent les américains
fassent justement cette requête de
dédommagement parce que certains
pourraient considérer que tout
simplement ces accusations aujourd'hui
sont contre-productives est ce qu'on n'a
pas besoin plutôt de l'aide de la chine
en ce moment pour essayer de lutter
contre cette épidémie est peut-être s'il
ya comptes à régler les régler après
quelques questions dans cette question
est la première réponse sécu
la réaction de la population est divisée
selon une frontière les partisans de
donald trump seront d'accord avec lui et
iront effectivement c'est la faute de la
chine
si les personnes n'aiment pas le
président alors ils seront enclins à
dire qu'il manque donc il ya cette ligne
politique qui divise les réactions et
cette frontière c'est également leur
vision du président qu'il a définie mais
s'agissant de ce qui se passe avec la
chine et la réaction avec sur cet aspect
certaines personnes directement très
inquiètes serait préoccupé par le fait
que la chine semble assez lot aider les
états unis s'agissant notamment de ses
équipements de protection qui n'arrive
pas mais ce n'est pas la faute de la
chine que les états unis arrêtez de
créer de produire ces équipements c'est
la grippe porcine qui a fait donc les
états unis qui produisent à l'époque
environ 90% de la production des
équipements de progression aujourd'hui
en tout cas matin c'est la chine qui
tient ce rôle depuis que nous sommes au
milieu d'une pandémie et l'espagne n'ont
pas la capacité de produire ce matériel
ce n'est pas un problème lié à la chine
c'est un problème américain
nous avons eu délocaliser toutes ces
entreprises qui permet de produire les
équipements médicaux nécessaires
donc maintenant car ne savons pas quoi
faire alors la chine de son côté l
al'inverse accuse les etats-unis de
s'exonérer de toute responsabilité pour
leur propre gestion de l'épidémie
ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un fond de
vérité là en sont je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de questions très légitime sur
l'origine du virus sur ce que savait la
chine est le véritable effet de la
pandémie en chine
si la chine avait été honnête au niveau
des statistiques mais cela ne changeait
en fait qu'en janvier et février lorsque
le virus
lorsque et amy était là son pic en chine
les etats unis ont commencé à envoyer
leurs équipements de protection en chine
nous avons vendu à la chine
et lorsque nous avions besoin sur notre
sol il y en avait plus à la racine de
tout cela c'est les perceptions
actuelles de la chine demande pourquoi
la chine ne fait rien alors que les
états unis souffrent mais c'est en fait
les politiques américaines qui sont en
cause de la souffrance américaine que
certains d'émilienne chine d'inde ou de
n'importe quel autre endroit où même des
états unis
même cela ne change rien au fait que les
états unis n'étaient pas bien équipés
pour la gérer merci beaucoup bonne soit
une journaliste d'investigation d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir